[Music]
i swear to god
by the way this is orlando yeah orlando
okay can i just say all right so like
we've all worked
we've all worked all sorts of retail
jobs we've all probably had to deal with
our fair share of crazies in our life
right yes is there nothing worse is that
one of the worst things ever is the type
of crazy person where their whole thing
is that they have no time they're busy
oh yeah they're busy they don't have
time and it's like you had time to cause
a disturbance you [ __ ] [ __ ]
well now she's pregnant and she's about
to have a miscarriage and i can sue the
[ __ ]
oh my god oh my god
royce what type is she is she faking
a miscarriage is she faking a
miscarriage i'll tell you this yeah
i'm naked oh my god
i'm a [ __ ]
what's going on
here
i started [ __ ] love in the camera hey
i'm
no way that's not good orlando probably
puerto rican
where am i going jail
victoria
oh no i'm having miscarried oh no i'm
having miscarriage ma'am you just stole
like 80 ketchup packets from the
mcdonald's and stuffed them in your room
we watched you do it we saw you do it we
we stood by yeah and wanted to see where
this went
chilly saying it's major consuela
[Music]
she's an idiot it's not
spirit airlines definitely puerto regan
also is this how it started yeah
yeah that was a super color okay
listen to me and let me show you
but i'm gonna lie i'm gonna show you
everything that you have i'm a cop i'm a
veteran so i'm gonna show you my
paperwork and i'm gonna show you fine
don't judge one time
okay
do not judge i'm pregnant
i think yes
guys guys don't don't forget
she's pregnant
you see what i just noticed
yeah ellen page is there no no no no
look at the guy looking through the
window over her shoulder hold on
like i was like what the [ __ ] he's
eating he's eating
what the [ __ ] is going on
[Laughter]
it's like a dinner at a show for him
yeah
don't touch the car
don't touch the car
it's recording
wow she is like already going in hard
is there a description is there a
description for this i don't i i'm
looking on september
19 2021 uh i along with officer
responded to gay 28 spirit airlines a
reference of disturbance while in route
the orlando communications center
advises the subject hispanic female had
struck one of the oh she hit one of the
gate attendants upon arrival at the gay
28 i was met spirit airlines gate agent
yashira bruno garcia and victoria
ramirez uh
garcia uh immediately pointed and
ramirez stated that ramirez hosts
osorio
see ramirez that doesn't narrow down
where they're from had struck her and
wanted to press charges ramirez
immediately became belligerent and
combative she told us that she was
pregnant and she was in the army and
that she was the police that she was the
police the sheriff and then she knew her
rights we escorted ramirez to the jet
bridge of gate 23 offers richard
assisted
me while officer whatever returned
okay so she so she was just she hit
somebody
i've been to this i've been at i've
flown out of this exact gate by the way
wait what are people yelling are those
was everyone kicked off the flight
don't come here come here let's get
appreciate you
guys
[Applause]
she's getting kicked off because she was
hitting people let's go over there
don't come here come here let's get away
from here this is too crowded right
over there
come with me okay
come with me
by the way they're not arresting her
still
okay just keep being great about this
follow me follow me
follow me
just follow me follow me sweetheart
let's go okay
and everything is all right
ah we can't go through here all right
okay
call me just follow me follow me follow
me follow me follow me
follow me
follow me
in the wheelchair
puerto rican
[Applause]
i'm sorry is this a flight to puerto
rico
jesus christ
let's see well hold on a second
where are they where's she flying to
september 19th 2021 11 36 p.m
gate 28 spirit airlines you could
probably backtrace that using flight
logs
[Applause]
wait what was it i want to see like a
five days oh you really think 828 yes
all right it's it's 9 19 20 21.
spirit airlines spirit airlines gate 28
orlando international airport flight
1049.
you got the fight number yeah yeah it's
right there
yes yes yes you're right
all right let's see if you can do this
i'll keep playing
oh
[ __ ] yeah i called it bro i [ __ ] goes
this is a flight to puerto rico hey uh
just yeah yeah uh it's it's gonna land
uh to just so you guys just so you guys
know uh today's plane is landing at 12
30 for uh
but yeah it is puerto rico yes that's a
puerto rican [ __ ] can't put that on me
hold on hold on though hold on though
this is
puerto rico oh
oh i know that's just the flight though
yeah yeah
yeah
come with me
by the way just looking at the people
waiting i'm like this flight's to puerto
rico or new york there's only two
options
puerto ricans only live in three places
new york orlando
or puerto rico
that's actually kind of cool that you
can find that yeah
come with me okay
it's okay take another l you [ __ ]
puerto ricans you steal our flag your
pieces of [ __ ]
shut up
okay good deal there you go
i feel like you have some sort of bias i
do it's genetic cubans and puerto ricans
don't like each other it's just the way
it is it's the [ __ ] circle of life
don't listen to this thing all right
and it's fine we're superior let's go
we're closer we we're closer in genetics
to spain than you are you [ __ ]
mongrels
i just don't even want to recognize him
forget forget forget white race realism
wait to get into hispanic race realism
it gets really [ __ ] quirky
to see them still left right there with
the [ __ ] minimum jobs there
over 100k a year
roshi makes over a hundred k a year
compt
and fly spirit airlines bucky yeah then
she doesn't make 100k a year
i don't give a [ __ ]
gonna be here you're puerto rican you
have the brain of a goldfish you'll
forget in an hour anyway uh totally not
puerto rican says oh please you tarts
fell for communist
guys we didn't fall for [ __ ] we're
overtaking about hey listen here [ __ ]
[ __ ] you doesn't have the balls to be
the 51st state but still wants all the
benefits you [ __ ] military island
full of welfare queens go [ __ ] yourself
liberal ass voting bunch of [ __ ]
[ __ ] island spicks get out of here
you [ __ ] get out of here at least i'm
self-aware what i am you [ __ ] you
won't oh we're part of a puerto rican
flag but we also we're america also go
[ __ ] yourself you know why because you
know why because you can fly a spirit
airline direct from orlando to puerto
rico without having to go through
customs because guess what you're
american you're a bunch of [ __ ]
losers sorry me too me too dee goo like
me too
what happened
he said i love when latinx's fight good
listen we need to go to the office let's
go i make 3 million a year he said as
the cops dragged him out of his 1999
toyota yaris
they're puerto rican it'd be a 1998
toyota camry
tan
yeah that hurts something you're right
it hurts to me because i'm right i know
it hurts somebody out there because i'm
right
air freshener
or no 1998 the cd the porter the cd that
looks like the puerto rican flag that
they hang yes how's that
yeah who is come on who be honest who
had the 1998 or 1999 tanned camry in the
chat be honest it was one of you [ __ ]
it's like the radio came pre uh
pre-programmed for reggaeton that's
although daddy yankee on [ __ ] luck
all day every day yeah
it was here it was 1998 it's grandpa
yankee yeah oh that's right yes yes
this is very patient with you let's go
yeah
tell me about my rice okay
get your manager to tell me that i need
to go there
from there
wait she's late she's saying get your
manager but like are these cops no these
are cops they're cops what manager
bente
shut up puerto rican
money
i make a hundred and twenty thousand wow
it's gone up 20 percent
what a year
he says royce and chad i'm totally
against the little flags of the river
just saying all right all right you
puerto rican all right if you say so
believe it when i see it you still bet
you used to wear jennifer lopez perfume
i don't want to hear it
from you
out of the essence by j.lo
[Music]
we have pitbull you have fat joe we are
not the same
[Laughter]
hispanic race war starting here
beans and rice war
[Laughter]
welcome to the 23rd annual day wave
beats and race war
oh [ __ ]
[Laughter]
get your manager
forget your manager
is the cup cuban i'm i'm i'm honestly
trying to list it in but it's hard cause
she keeps screaming over him
all right oh my god
come on
get your manager to tell me that i need
to get there
or an attorney
i'm starting to think she wasn't in the
military a cop or made 120 000 a year or
had sushi compt in vegas and i'm
starting with that that's not a food
baby yeah i'm starting to wonder if that
she just had too much [ __ ] too much
fungal or
what other [ __ ] drunk
yeah well she's definitely drunk a
little bit too much bacardi oh yeah
something else you [ __ ] puerto rican
thief stole from us bacardi was a cubic
company and then instead of helping us
out with communism you just [ __ ] took
our rum business but that's our rum
it'll never be your rum you hear that
you hear that it's on vacation there in
your little [ __ ] war island
sorry
[Laughter]
like you have thought about this for a
long time it's not thought about brumq
but i was indoctrinated my whole family
thinks this way i am indoctrinated
[Laughter]
[Laughter]
and i thought my people were angry at
the chinese you guys i [ __ ] heard you
so don't pretend like i'm crazy
there's something so dude even coming
from this crazy chick yeah i don't know
what it is
but there's something so warm and
comforting to me like i actually calm
down when when i hear a woman in a thick
latinx and go it's okay it's okay it's
okay it's okay it's okay like she could
pee nuts and i just like
okay it's gonna be okay it's okay
it's gonna be charging with resisting
don't understand what i'm saying i'm
pregnant the cop's also puerto rican
so it's a double puerto rican here
and i can see this [ __ ]
you know what they say two puerto ricans
don't make a white
oh my god i'm in pain
oh my god oh my god oh my gosh
[Laughter]
i lick it i lick it i lick it i lick it
okay oh my
i don't think miscarriages work like
that
wait if you go back a little bit and you
turn it up i think you can is she pete i
think you can hear her peeing come on
let me see no pessi hold on okay go back
more go back more it's it's it's when
she started yelling like
okay like a right around here turn it up
it might just be me
oh my [ __ ] god
oh my god
no that's not her peeing that's just
like it seems like something's rattling
rubbing against his uh mike okay
yeah yeah that's something rubbing
against his mic
and
[ __ ] i'm
baby
i'm
losing
my
well spirit if you if you do lose your
baby because of spirit don't worry
they'll give you a free 50 voucher for
next time you fly
excludes puerto
[ __ ] the rico
ambulance look at what the [ __ ] is
looking at me you don't see my child's
coming out
this cop's just looking at okay ma'am
i'm looking at your vagina this
particular individual instructed me to
look at her vagina
can we skip ahead a little bit because
this is a long video so closely saying
that woman lives with cubans random
section here you go
at some point
you want to lay down
um
imagine being a cop and just watching
this whole thing
yeah
just to weird out my partner i'd lean in
and i'd go
this is exactly why i became a cop
i would do that too that'd be [ __ ]
hilarious
this is what makes the job worth it and
just walk away
yeah we yeah we protect people yeah we
stop the bad guy but is it really worth
it if this doesn't happen once again
[Music]
the radio has to be a [ __ ] can
you bring a uh
a statement and a uh
that's what i thought they were pregnant
yeah
my friend
with her [ __ ] co
i don't know this [ __ ]
check a wrecker he's still a [ __ ]
footstep
she's an average puerto rican woman and
it's an average day at the orlando
airport to be honest with you guys
is
you flew into orlando right yeah i was
orlando i picked you up at yeah
yeah huh it was like gay 28 did you sit
in the p chair
you don't know you might have hey you
might have sat in the picture yeah i
might have set the uh
they call it when it's like when it's a
mix of pee miscarriage and and come
they're called satan's rainbow
this is this is gay 28 which is the one
that's right in front of the bathroom
and i have taken the biggest shits of my
life in these bathrooms
um the trick is you go to the one in the
middle that's for you know unisex or for
you know disability ones that's just
your own bathroom with a door and you
close it [ __ ] in that one pro tip life
hack
okay
and then if they look at you when you're
getting out you look at me go aids am i
right and you keep walking
they usually leave you alone when you
mention it's an aids really get your
hands on their face and go i love you
[Laughter]
how you felt the real citizen that makes
me
it makes me mad that i was there
so percy when you left
uh orlando was it
like this
well well no he didn't wait did you flew
out of orlando also right yeah yeah yeah
okay so it was both i don't remember if
you did like orlando than tampa okay so
weirdly i don't know what was going on
but i think it's because i was flying
back into toronto
it was mostly indian
oh you were on the international side of
the airport you don't even know you
don't even get the real experience yeah
i didn't get that that's not you didn't
get the real experience
puerto rico isn't it
no puerto rico it's not an international
flight it really isn't huh puerto rico
again it's since it's an america it's
america now you got him going again no
i'm just not i'm not trying to be
saying
puerto rico is america puerto rico's
america what are you saying is puerto
rico is not even a country yeah puerto
rico is not even a country so puerto
rico is one of our
is also not a state hey puerto rico
you're [ __ ] nothing
actually it's really just a play in
football yeah you know what you are
you're a port for carnival cruise people
to puke on
there you go there it is oh i'm gonna
authentic puerto rican food i'm gonna
have the senor frogs at the port you
[ __ ] you marks um
[ __ ] that's the beauty of karma karma
comes around what
the fact that it's been 48 minutes and
they haven't arrested you yet shows you
the absolute restraint of these officers
right
nice kicks
back on you fell as an officer
i'm an officer and i don't even feel
that bad but did she like reverse
miscarriage what's going on she's fine
now the miscarriage is just victorian
did he call it the ambulance it was the
bamber lambs did he call them
did he really call it that
[ __ ] puerto rican cup
um
jesus christ
i live here frozen so go [ __ ] yourself
you see what's happening on your screen
i live here
why do you think i'd rather drive to
[ __ ] new york now
by the way i do love my logic it's like
[ __ ] i'm getting away from puerto ricans
let me go to new york where there's
even more puerto ricans
and ride there with a long islander i
know this is hell
if it's me too
you're looking at it
no no it's okay you're looking
and she's continuing to refuse
the orders and now she's gonna make it
have a seat
leave me alone leave me alone don't
touch me cause you have to write the
time
please please let the please let
paramedic brian regan look at you
hold on forget about my son right now
right now forget about my kid right now
we care about [ __ ] making justice
exactly you know what the game was 8 20.
victoria can you
record i'm a [ __ ]
this is what she said she said if i
don't want her to get on a plane it's
okay
why she's taking off her clothes again
because when a puerto rican feels
defensive they take off their clothes
and get into fighting stance
this is normal the shirts off
earrings next
fight stance
okay guys say do you think that's right
do you think it's right to just like a
little pretty i thought it was like a
lizard where
if it gets rid of its tail
the predators stop coming after it like
i know it's not like that now puerto
ricans nope in the car they lost like i
said they're jlo by essence by jlo colon
pheromones
to attract other puerto rican men to
defend her
guys who do their eyebrows and stuff it
looks like eddie kingston be like what
up girl
what up eddie geeks and
please bubble coats bubble coats it i
got it i'm already doing it busy
renaming renaming the episode to beans
and rice war please
i could do that i could do that hold on
[Laughter]
hold on i'm doing it right now
uh uh uh update title what do you want
me to call it beans and rice or beans
hold on beans
i'll do the you know what i'm gonna do
the amber sand beans and because holy
[ __ ]
i'm [ __ ] [ __ ]
what up girl are these cops bugging you
i've never heard someone
within the span of an hour
say my fungo so many times
such disgust
yes it's smooshed banana farts i don't
want it
hey
you always look you're always looking
for day wave clips i think we found our
day wave clip tell that to taper
well i'm gonna try something
i'm gonna try something see if this
works
uh hold on
how do you use
don't be don't be a jerk um
come on work
there it is
uh
okay
give me a second hope this is worth it
all right uh
and
image
okay
all right
okay
all right
i'm on work
yeah it's gonna work
okay yeah her pheromones have attracted
have attracted another puerto rican man
to come help her hold on here we go
yo what up girl these pigs bugging you
hey what up girl
she was like
oh well
i don't [ __ ] like her and you don't
want your pictures there and your
[ __ ] and your [ __ ] there
it's okay that's okay
you okay though veronica let's go home
sorry bro let's [ __ ] go dude it's not
worth it babe
babe it's not worth it babe babe it's
not worth it
baby
don't talk to my wife that way dogs
that i could have been in a [ __ ]
place and you did not care and then you
have everybody you really ate me
you many hated me you had everybody
laughing at me
because you wanted to be a [ __ ] you
wanted to take one [ __ ] wait so it's
the cops fault that people are laughing
at her
the problem was that you hit somebody i
think is more the issue here right let
her go sorry [ __ ]
take a deep breath for me i heard you
now i listen to you listen to me can you
hear me no but she just she answers this
and everything
you gave me a [ __ ] blind linda
somebody in the chat says they're just
letting her tire herself out
you don't understand you don't
understand puerto rican women that's not
going to happen
how about the [ __ ] mistreatment that
you get [ __ ] better i understand
baby
that's okay to [ __ ] believe all the
[ __ ] students just because they don't
[ __ ] like it oh
i don't like her it's okay she'll gotta
get her fly really victoria calm down i
heard you now you said it to me
twice you i love him she's spitting him
she's spitting oh that's what happened
and there it is
how about the [ __ ] mistreatment that
you get [ __ ] better
gotta get to [ __ ] myself and give me
a [ __ ] fly and fire a [ __ ] that
think that's okay to [ __ ] believe all
the [ __ ] students just because they
don't [ __ ] like
oh
i don't like her it's okay see all the
students
yeah you know also those crazy people
that also
they swear a lot and i don't know what
it is it's like when they get the yell
yelling
and then saying [ __ ] a lot i don't know
if it's to just disorient you mm-hmm
but
yeah it's it's it's basically like a
it's a natural defense mechanism
yeah like hold on you're gonna get it
offline really victoria calm down i
heard you now you said it to me twice i
heard you spit
i shouldn't have done that
now you're oh boy oh she shouldn't have
done that
victoria um
i put in the locker a classic video that
reminds like this is like this kind of
swearing right like it's a minute long
but uh you've seen this right with the
two uh yes yeah
yeah it just reminds me of that
like they they know that it's bad words
but they don't know how they use them
properly in a sentence
yeah if you wanna go then you'll go to
hill and go down oh
[ __ ] mother bloody [ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ]
i [ __ ] you bloody
bloody bastard [ __ ] running like lady
yeah
i love you i i i love i love i love
british culture
percy knows i i went [ __ ]
i see this every day on the street
little indianapolis news has to look out
his window little india shout out to me
why are you starting at me wait because
i am going to the work exclusion don't
you do to other places why are you
shouting
[Music]
well i mean at least it ended nicely
this won't
put her
you wanna know you see that you see the
blade that you touch make sure you uh
oh man this guy has a [ __ ] a pip boy
double waffle face
do you think
whoa n bomb definitely puerto rican
cubans don't say the n bomb that's a
puerto rican trait you want to know why
i can't say why
um
sir i've heard you off air well then you
know why
[Laughter]
we will get
it shut up you didn't get it before
cannot stop
that's over [ __ ] two thousand dollars
a day these puerto rican chicks in the
chatter hillary baby bibi by the way you
haven't said yo [ __ ] on god and clapped
your hands and you're not really puerto
rican then you're lying
i don't believe it
can you do that can you at least do that
get my phone my phone is over there
a free valet service and everything look
at that
[ __ ] you a free ride okay get my [ __ ]
i'll put it on the wrist
and i'm gonna see my laptop because
that's over three thousand dollars
a laptop is a gaming laptop
get my stuff right
ma'am this is a chromebook it's 200 on
amazon
get my stuff it's right here no i wanna
stop with me come back over please
don't forget guys tomorrow is prime day
which means you could get only amazon
based products on the front page for 10
off
and they're all going to be listening
devices
your prime day's the same as our prime
day right
yes okay our prime prime day is tomorrow
so you know what that means guys you
want a sh do you want a shitty amazon
tablet with spyware on it
huh no i'm i'm i'm waiting for all that
cheap um
chinese technology that's bound my way
oh i can't wait right
now three thousand dollars damien goes
it's not a gaming laptop there's just an
entry-level apple laptop jesus christ
apple rips people off he's right
you think i don't know my right [ __ ]
like i'm a [ __ ] cop i'm on my right
uh-huh well right now you're going to be
[ __ ] rolled out to the car
oh she's trying to run she's trying to
run
[Music]
um i ate his liver with my fungo and a
coquito
hey clarice are the pigs screaming
oh cool she gets to see the cool accent
that nobody gets to normally see that's
cool right
but the cherry picker yes you get to see
the secret exit
i haven't got this ending on stanley's
parable yet
have you
no oh the angry latina and ending yeah
yeah you have to hold the bucket to get
it
okay this is completely no one's going
to understand this unless they played
stanley variable but me and felkrate
played through that game like for two
hours with the bucket and it just kept
giving us new [ __ ] that game is
oh i know insane
what a host of a female cop huh what a
unit
they're standing back because i don't
want to get spit on
she just jason statham's the [ __ ] out of
them in the closed elevator oh my god
or does like the [ __ ] captain america
elevator fight
she's quiet now that she doesn't have an
audience all the music right here is bow
put the count put down put down but i
got the bomb put the gown put down put
down but i got the bunker and she's like
[ __ ] rips the handcuffs off she just
kicks and [ __ ] snaps one
aren't you the one pretending to be a
cop
being pregnant
this this is awesome to interview by the
way
just filling out a fat potato puerto
rican out of the orlando airport this is
the beginning of wolfenstein too
seriously
welcome to welcome to
welcome to orlando international airport
agent 47
your mission is to get this high-ranking
puerto rican official
victoria consuela the killer ramirez off
the street
she's currently in orlando pd custody
they call him miscarriage on account of
her always yelling about her
miscarriages
yes you know my kids and my boy
to jail
[Music]
[Laughter]
orange county jail where's orange county
it's the county you're in ma'am
is this in aberdeen costello bit
where
first base
i don't like oranges
where is that at a brc can we go to
mojito county
what you mean where am i going actually
i have a right to know where i'm going
i'm going to go to the orange county
jail sorry i got it where am i going but
where am i going
[Music]
where am
bro
it's really
she is
in so long i know this needs
i got it
you know what this sounds like a trap
song
[Music]
i thought there we go i used to whip on
the style no i can't i didn't get your
medals
here we go
[Applause]
in the airport and spit on them and you
slap the kid attendant
you're under arrest for battery why
battery i didn't do [ __ ] to you
you mad at me because i tell you that
you're about you guys victoria you're
going to win yes yes they're mad at you
because you're a truth teller
why have i gone to jail
i need to go to just
thanks okay
how long was this video just 48 minutes
shut the [ __ ] up for the entirety of the
whole thing
i told you i'm not going to tire
yourself out you don't listen to me
about to lose it when she got me with
that spit
i gotta get it though imagine being
[ __ ] spit on right
i was about to smack the crap he's still
being recorded i was about to smack the
crap out of him and then then i remember
and then you see the other guy just
tapping his like
oh dave he did it again
the flight crew closed the aircraft door
before ramirez could board the flight
while uh garcia was still in the
jeopards ramirez struck garcia and
another passenger in the head they were
not injured and refused medical
attention
uh while i was the kid 23 ramirez was
being disorderly screaming and shouted
topper lungs ramirez behavior rappers
victor ramirez was charged with battery
and disorderly intoxication she was
drunk uh respectfully first and
second-degree misdemeanors after a
recent hearing regarding the competency
followed by a cancelled change of plans
change of plea hearing
it appears that ramirez has decided to
take her case to trial which is now
except for july 18 20. why would you
take this to trump right
why would you take if you get a plea
deal and probably honestly
if she's a first-time offender which it
kind of looks like it
you're gonna get no you're gonna get
community service you won't even get
probation
what an idiot
oh these people they're [ __ ] so dumb
and by these people i mean puerto ricans
oh here we go
okay just actually case somebody's
confused i don't want people we got five
minutes left i don't want to say people
are racist